اهلا بكم في كوكب اليابان الكوكب الذي
يشهد تقدما تقنيا وتراجعا بشريا
فاليابانيون لا ينجبون
يتراجع في اليابان عدد السكان للعام
الثاني عشر على التوالي الحكومه وضعت خطه
لصرف 25 مليار دولار سنويا لتشجيع الانجاب
بعد تراجع معدل الخصوبه الى واحد فاصله
اثنين بالعشره
اعتقد ان الحكومه يجب ان تقلل من ضغط
تربيه الاطفال وان تقدم لنا المزيد من
الدعم يجب ان يستثمروا اكثر في موارد
التعليم في الوقت الحاضر لا يرغب الكثير
من الناس في انجاب الاطفال اذا لم يكن
لديهم الموارد لتوفير تعليم جيدا لهم
اذا بقي الامر على حاله سينخفض عدد سكان
اليابان خلال الاربعين سنه القادمه من 125
مليون الى 87 مليون نسمه والامر لا ينحصر
فقط في اليابان
صحيفه تحذر من عواقب اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
وخيمه سكان الكوكب سيتراجعون مع نهايه
القرن وذلك للمره الاولى منذ تفشي الطاعون
الاسود في القرن الرابع عشر
من البلدان مثل الصين واليابان وسنغافوره
وتايوان كانوا يحاولون اشياء مختلفه
لتحقيق معدل نمو اعلى في عدد السكان كان
هذا من خلال الحوافز الماليه لانجاب
الاطفال لكن هذه الامور لم تكن فعاله مثل
ما رايناه في بعض البلدان الاخرى مثل
المانيا وبعض الدول الاوروبيه
في العالم منها الصين والهند والولايات
المتحده عدد من يموتون سنويا يتجاوز عدد
من يولدون
تراجعت معدلات الخصوبه مع بدايه الالفيه
الجديده من 2.7 الى اثنين فاصله ثلاثه
واذا وصلت الى اثنين في العشره اي كل
زوجين ينجبان طفلين فقط فهذا يعني ان
البشر سيبداون في التناقص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات